foreign
there are a few books that have been
brought up on this podcast more than
that one very few and Victor frankl's
story
survival of four concentration camps
just generous heroic
the thing is a lot of people stop
reading halfway through the first book
that they touch of his because the story
is really powerful but then you get to
this stuff about logo therapy and some
people say that he was part of the Triad
of Austrian
Pioneers in the way we think about the
mind there was Freud who focused on
sensuality and sex there was Adler who
focused on status dominance and then
there was Frankel who focused on meaning
and meaning as far as I can tell from my
limited reading of Frankel's work
is
when a human being finds
a thing that means something to them a
chance for a path forward a pathway to
Hope
everything in their life gets better
and that his work he lived for another
70 years after he got out of the camp 65
years his work he and suicide prevention
was extraordinary from the statistics
I've read because he understood that for
many people I'm not generalizing
everyone but for many people
finding a path toward hope of meaning of
realizing that the struggle is the
struggle but you get to decide what to
do with it
is really profound and I think as our
industrialized world has gotten more
narcissistic which basically says
marketers need to make you uncomfortable
so that you will buy more stuff to feel
better about yourself and your standing
marketers are trying to push people to
find meaning in purchases
and the problem with that also in
friends and likes and social media
nonsense the problem with that is it
doesn't scale
and after you've got one storage room
full of stuff buying more things doesn't
seem to help you find more meaning
and I really feel like we're in this
moment in our culture This Moment In
Time
where people are waking up and saying
thank you very much but I don't need to
buy another thing what I need to do is
find something to care about
and I'll finish this with a two-parter
about I went to see a community
Orchestra last week my friend is in it
all volunteers and the thing about
Community orchestras is there are
violinists and flautists and noblests
who get paid money to do it
but no one in the community Orchestra is
saying why aren't I getting paid
because that's not why they're there in
fact they often pay to be there
and I'm guessing with no data whatsoever
that if you surveyed people who are in
community orchestras they probably index
happier and more engaged in life than
people who aren't
and so the question is where are we
going to find our community Orchestra
for me the last year and a half it was
the carbon Almanac I have 1900 friends
in 90 countries around the world I ran
into a bunch of them yesterday Union
Square and they're not doing it for
money none of us got paid they're not
doing it for me I wasn't even there
until I showed up at the end of the day
they're doing it because the meaning
that they get from it is so valuable
it gives them a reason to put up with
all the other stuff they have to do
every day